there's a galaxy with no dark matter  that's challenging the very paradigm  which cosmologists have believed for  years and this is posing a huge  challenge to astronomers who have pinned  their hopes on the existence of  particles known as wimps how did a  galaxy seemingly emerge into existence  without any dark matter to cedar it  could be something has stripped the  galaxy of just its dark matter so that  would require some contrivances we'd  have to think of a mechanism through  which the dark matter could get stripped  away and completely rendered invisible  it's a huge mystery now astronomers make  the simplification that you can actually  trace the distribution of matter  luminous matter the matter that we can  see we can't see dark matter after all  at least not yet and maybe not ever if  it doesn't exist and that's why  astronomers are so challenged when they  discovered